Bo loop doop boop ba-lep bep buh
Be Bep boop boop ba doop boop ba daah-
Beh da boop ba
Bep balep beh bah
Ah *Imitates car alarm* ba doop
Okay, ooOh
Ahlee?
NOW
WOW!
I'm a wiZArd!
Pick up items with the left trIGGER
Holy shitballs! I got a staff and a hand
With glowy's on it!  Im a wizard ha-
arr-rgrid.
Hello, everybody! My name is Markiplier
And I can't see you because I'm in the Wizarding World of left hand path
This is my left hand!  It may look like it's on the right for you, ya-buh but you'd be wrong
Because on my left. now in left hand path. This is a world where magic is real
OOOH
Look at that magic I just did -  bluh, pbht
Even the voices in the distance are responding to the siren call of my magic
Oh, I love my nails God. Got a good manicure
Hep-  wow that was not a book the well of all reward awaits you. Once in the well
Left trigger to summon arcane power and grasp items left pad to blink
What? Wait...
Oh.
Those were two different sentences
Left pad to blink. Right application button for menu and difficulty settings health is ruins remaining on your left hand
Saves happen on death or at the screaming - at ah- at any old screaming head- at A screaming head not the screaming head
We who watch wish your soul well. We who watch apparently bled all over this sheet of paper
Why was that necessary? "Descend the stairs to enter the well." Well Heidi didee ho, here we fucking go,
la dee
Fucking where's my goddamn desk how close am I to you guys you tell me  oh I'm bumping I bumped something oh
WOOOAAAH
I've got magic shooting out of my doONG
Owwwww *Screaming*
Boink Wow okay
"So"
(possibly) "Thats all I know"
No
*sigh* "its- its ah good to have this
"Time together with ya"
"We've got so much promise(?)"
Huh?
"Now why don't you start by giving us some light? Remember what I told ya"
"Draw the... Zed shape..."
"In the air, with ya left hand" Waa? hang on I gotta cr- I gotta create a new character here wait. Oh, this will immediately oh
Never mind
Oh arachnophobia mode replaces spider like enemies with non spider like ones. I  recommend only enabling this if you really can't enjoy a game
without it
Well, I mean if you guys don't like spiders. I'm sorry. I have Tripta phobia if you have arachnophobia
We're all just gonna tough this through I wore the phobia hat in our latest charity livestream
So I think you guys can get through this because I believe in you
for whatever that matters low terror mode *spits in disgust*
for less intense with less scary experience Oh
Im a Big bitch, baby that needs this ..enable don't look at me, naw I'm not gonna enable it
Okay, all right Zed sign whatever Zed means
HAAAAAA SebenIAAAA DA Badisss Baboyy
Ohhh   OHHH HI!
WoWie "oh yes, very good"
"Remember where we are now It's truly dangerous"
"Heavens forfend you'll ever face those dangers, but if you do.."
"Blinking away will be your greatest friend." Okay. "You'll need to practice this. Here's a danger now. Dont try and fight"
Heey Hey HEY!! BLINK AWAY FROM YOU, HOW? YOU DIDNT TELL ME HOW!! UHHH
How do I, oh ohhhh "Very good, there's a new sign be careful with it? It's called Vees" Vees?
"Dangerous, it's dangerous to your foe too"
"us it, they are coming now"
Vees Vees VEes Vees! whoops Vees goes here. Oh I get it. I am a wizard look at me wizard
I'm gonna wizard you now
BAM bitch ohhhhh
Shit, you're dead "Its time to go I can sense it" mmm. Yeah
I am  "You have somuch potential" Oh I got  so much potential "know as the wise we store what we have learned in our grimoire"
Ill show you a grimoire" with your seals Just bring your staff to your forehead it will appear in front of you"
oh
"Thats it Well done" ah
"have a look through it now"
AWW my brains
I
Can teach you?
When you're edgy
Aha look desk. Oh hang on I got to really think about this
What the hell oh
cool
This game really cool. Okay. I'm sorry this game is really cool. Is it still running all right cool
I don't know why but this games really cool, and what's this?
White light oh
Oh, it's still blue
All right, never mind, then I'm gonna go over to the table. Hey. How's it going sweet table thing?
Jaron
I've got gem right here. You're talking about jam Ram. Oh wait hang on this you're talking about this wait. No this ah
Jai Ram Jai Ram husk
Humors
greater spells of funniness you talking about
Are you talking about improv guys wait? I've got the most powerful spell of all
It's still a viable way oh oh
I'm sorry look that there's a task. I need to see through. Uh-huh we will continue later
Okay, all right well all right then well
I'm a beautiful young wizard
And you see so much potential in me is what I heard about that one
I know a simple stroke of magic thus Z will banish the dark all right
So I'll stroke your magic. Thusly swim swam WOM ooh
wait no Oh
Baby I got the magic Oh No look at this fireball Oh, Oh what is that?
Oh wow Oh
Wham baby whoa hey whoa watch yourself bring your dog to your for remember what you know? Oh do I?
remember
Wait oh, I think I'm getting a memory. Oh there. We are spell of the laughing
The greater spell laughing bah. Oops sorry about that
BA hat crass arm
pure magic
ritual pebbles D boo shooby wahby
debit
circle protection
Some like this problem, okay sure won't go with that one. Whoa whoa whoa oh?
Wow what is that hello?
Wow that's whoo that's terrifying how about some true magic?
Yeah, that's a long way down. What's in here?
Fucking holy shit bags on a dicking stick
What the heck heck?
Scared the piss out of me god dammit. I'm sorry you alright here. Let me draw a nice circle. Oh
Geez okay, alright. He's alright. He's gonna walk it off. Everybody's calm down calm down now everything's fine
Don't worry about it. How the skins cool this game. Also feels good when I'm going through it like it doesn't feel
Janky, it doesn't feel disorienting. It doesn't feel anything like that
It's just like it's very smooth, and it works really well
You see me
True magic oh this guy sees me
Good thing I'm naked
Hi, anybody around the Oh
Hey, wait a minute
Hey, wait a minute Oh
Some don't feel right about all the will. Oh excuse me, sorry about that some don't feel right about all this all right
Whatever you say
What are you ah friendly Danny fire the most basic of human requirements can be used as a common?
name
Name No
Ah
Ow
My staff is on fire now that doesn't seem good. Oh oh
I meant to do that. I totally meant to do that excuse me can I have you?
Whoa I think he's watching me this place
Just gets worse strange noises outside the walls
No windows horrible sounds from the kitchen fire screaming and pleading ever since the night where the lightning struck
And we heard them both laughing I wonder if we died that day if we're in hell and now he's watching me
I don't know why he would when he says magic is so rare and valuable
But I hears breathing at night what she'd do if she found out. I don't even want to think I hope it's true
I hope we're only here for a little while longer, but I don't believe it
fascinating okay alright then fire
Okay about fire in the here fire like it. Love it. Love it fire light the whole place on fire
Everything on fire scares me fire. It's gotta be something. I'm missing right
Burn this down burn this down
Hello oh ah
Hi
Hello
Can I just do one of these maneuvers?
Let me just uh huh no
Not not today. All right. How do I open you all right? Everybody hold on to your hats. It's about to get exploding in here
Boom no okay, all right, then I'm just like oh
There we go
Whoo this door does not appear to open from this side, okay?
You know what? Yeah? Whoa? How did I get all the way here? Oh wait a minute? Ah?
Okay, ah
All right
oh
Look at you
man, Oh
Lower your head ow ow my head ow okay? I guess I'm down here now
I don't even know if you guys could see me whew she's
Beautiful who's in here? Oh? I don't like the look of that at all. Oh who's there? Huh all right? Okay?
All right, okay?
Who's here, huh?
Subject for male estimated age 45 acquired on road attempted robbery of myself and my wife
Hmm fire on the extremities no response ingestion of vitriol. No response subject clearly in agony and fear of life, but
Malakand does not respond and the void remains unfulfilled sacrifice with silver and moon and no response, okay. He's dead. Oh. He's very dead
Hello, you okay?
Yo, you're right
You okay
buddy
You all right kisses make everything better all right, let's go this way then I guess whoo
Spooky okay, all right then ooh, that's that's not good. That's okay. Sorry Oh
Who's there oh
Don't come any closer maybe
Really tried to warn you about that one that was a
Clear as day clear stay here. Take this to fix you right up. There you go, buddy
Okay, never mind
Then let's see a breakthrough as we cut into the four made ill my husband ever so reluctant but determined to cook forced
His way through the passage he was clearly overcome with passion and for the first time the void stirred
It was not enough, but it seems the connection is key stars in a new
Silver to attend Vic and copper knife Macallan invoked twice before the release still attempt to reproduce
Okay, oh boy here we go
Jack came
Consume those items which respond to garam to reap husk from them from B becomes power small cost as all the wise should know
Begin with the key make haste to lower your staff with that the powers may form
Conjure mmm to the east and that to the west. Okay. I
Thought I already did that okay? All right? Is that chamber pot there piss on that oh hell
Yeah, I hope so let me get a look in there. Yeah, this shit. All right
Well, let me a good chamberpot
Hello, you splatoon can I wear you on my hood no
Sorry, I'm out here. Let's go towards the blue flame. Hello. Let's go towards the blue flame whoa
Hey, whoa, hey whoa whoa?
Whoa whoa well one fear. I'm dead. I'm you were defeated. Okay. I'm dead now again. I guess okay
Well
Not exactly what I would call fair all right. Whatever that was really really cool
I like that a lot so that was the left-handed path not bad by any stretch of the imagination
Definitely deep into the fantasy aspects of things which is something that I haven't seen out of virtual reality normally always horror
But that was scary, but also really cool, so I don't know if I'm gonna play anymore for videos, but that was really nice
So thank you everybody so much for watching
Let me know if you want to see more of this down in the comments below and as
Always, I'll see you in the next video. Bye